direction la célèbre place pouchkine à
moscou le restaurant qui abritait
mcdonald's rouvre ses portes dimanche
avec un nouveau nom et un nouveau logo
la chaîne américaine a décidé de vendre
tous ses restaurants en russie après
l'invasion de moscou en ukraine on
retrouve notre envoyé spécial k reen
achats bourse et l'ouverture officielle
du nouveau mcdo en ce moment
juste derrière moi qui est en train de
se produire actuellement vous l'avez dit
un nouveau nom alors que l'on pourrait
traduire par le goût point final où le
goût c'est tout un nouveau logo vous le
voyez sans doute derrière moi c'est un
rond rouge sur fond vert avec des barres
latérales à orange qui symbolise le
burger et les frites c'est un logo qui a
été très commentée voir critiqué ces
derniers temps sur les réseaux sociaux
un nouveau patron alexandre gover c'est
un homme d'affaires russe qui exploitait
déjà une quinzaine de restaurants
mcdonald's dans le pays et qui est bien
à de très grandes ambitions pour sa
nouvelle marque puisqu'il bleus il
insiste il va conserver tous les emplois
tous les restaurants ouvriront
progressivement les 850 mais il souhaite
aussi en ouvrir 150 supplémentaires
d'ici cinq ans quant au goût et bien ici
on nous l'a sur les ingrédients seront
les mêmes ou presque un compte tenu des
difficultés d'approvisionnement alors il
n'y aura plus évidemment de big mac mais
des burgers comme celui ci au goût
effectivement on a pu le constater à ses
semblables et avec un élément important
vous le voyez c'est le ruban de saint
georges sur l'emballage de rubans de
saint-georges qui a un symbole
patriotique de la victoire allemande de
la victoire russe pardon sur l'allemagne
nazie et la date est très symbolique
aujourd'hui pourquoi
écouter ici c'est aujourd'hui le 12 juin
c'est la fête de la russie c'est un jour
férié le plus récent dans l'histoire
russe qui marque l'indépendance de la
fédération de russie vis-à-vis de
l'union soviétique et c'est l'occasion
de tout un tas d'événements de
célébration de concerts patriotti
vladimir poutine remettra des médailles
à des personnalités et on voit un des
drapeaux russe partout dans les rues et
puis surtout cette ouverture aujourd'hui
elle est très symbolique puisque c'est
ici vous savez que mcdonald's est la
première enseigne occidental à ouvrir un
fast food il ya 32 ans sur cette place
pouchkine est clairement le message que
l'on souhaite afficher c'est que la
russie résiste aux sanctions qu'elle
peut se passer des grandes marques
occidentales
quant aux russes qui souhaiteraient et
bien pouvoir continuer à profiter de
marques occidentales ils pourront
toujours se tourner vers kfc ou encore
burger king en deux enseignes
américaines qui l ont fait le choix de
rester dans le pays